معنى ذلك بان باننا مقبلون برايك على
موجات تصعيد اضافيه وجديده
والامور مسدوده فيما يتعلق بالوصول الى
تهدئه
في في ظل موازين القوى والاحداث التي حصلت
حتى اللحظه
يعني من ناحيه اسرائيل الرهان الان ان لا
تدخل كتائب القسام تحديدا بقوه في هذا
التصعيد معظم المسؤول المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين يتجنبون الحديث عن دور حماس
في هذه المواجهه لا يريدون لا يريدون
الاشاره لها حتى انهم تجنبوا ما اعتادوا
على قوله منذ سنوات عندما كانت تطلق رصاصه
واحده من قطاع غزه حتى لو اطلقت بالخطا
كانت اسرائيل تقول ان حماس هي المسؤوله عن
ذلك حتى لو لم يكن احد عناصرها الذي اطلق
النار بحكم انها هي التي تسيطر على قطاع
غزه هذا الخطاب غائب تماما وكما
اشير في التقرير من يمين نتنياهو رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه قمع وزير الطاقه
اسرائيل كانت فقط لمجرد تلميحه الى
امكانيه
اغتيال قاده حماس في حاله
الظهور الفعلي لمشاركه حماس في في التصعيد
اسرائيل تحاول ان تحقق انجازاتها وتحاول
في نفس الوقت الوقت تجنب دخول المقاومه
بكافه قدراتها في المواجهه لان ذلك سيقضي
على الفكره التي تسعى اسرائيل الى
التحقيقها عبر هذا